the envelopes please mr. Klein may we
hear the sound of the envelope therapist
[Music]
you open the doors alright the winner is
and the winner is and the Oscar goes to
the Oscar goes to
and the Oscar goes to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do you understand English
absolutely mapa good lord
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Academy governor representing the
producers branch and chair of the
Foreign Language Film Award Executive
Committee mark Johnson thank you good
morning good morning to the casts and
crews who are here today from our five
nominated films good morning to the
directors all five or are with us and
good morning to the Foreign Press who
have been covering this event for some
time we had a number of you downstairs
taking a lot of pictures lots of
interviews a little over three months
ago we started watching 92 movies in
many in this very theater double
features a lot on the Crosstown and the
Linwood done it turns out that the very
first movie we saw this season was
Lebanon's the insult and
and the very last one was Hungary's on
body and soul both of course both of
them nominated this year it's a very
time-consuming and grueling process you
can imagine seeing 92 movies I think I
myself I think I saw about little over
60 so it's sort of we shut down our our
personal lives are in this period but we
wouldn't change it for anything for just
the surprise and delight of seeing all
these movies for the first time many I
think we were close to 400 people
participated in in this committee this
year many of those dedicated and
passionate committee members are here so
I'd like all of you to please stand up
and take a bow
[Applause]
I'm so proud to be a member of this
committee and to be sitting alongside
all of you before I introduce our five
directors I would like to share with you
glimpses of some of the movies that some
members mesmerized us and what is here
today let's start with our first clip
from Chile a fantastic woman
Sebastian Bell yo writer director
producer
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
which is - not just didn't whenever
seven OMA their London Ethel will say
one beautiful
ICS
[Music]
[Applause]
Gracia the way a try you know Esposito
Gracia he okay show me sanglug are you
- yum yum or contour Tomczyk a little
valium Porto pasta here like adhirata he
was Orlando no no no no medium in the
real-estate the matter yet not a little
mundo ha ha
and the Atheist we put you multiple
hundreds a melodies to them don't I come
down see the local trailer in Guinea
kilometres over yo he he lost any
economy gonna song II anomic redundant
to tell over here probably what it when
the means is he
[Music]
the start
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to the sea
to
how didn't give a little safe
from Hungary on body and soul ylva CO
and Yeti writer/director
[Applause]
you wanna put my could idler your it's
valued
well not for semiconductor I found Mon
téléphone you chuckles condo you like
what your kid should call him is being
that's not your of solution I am Steve
McClaren oh god no music no garlic Hyrum
dog was kamek fidelium banana which is
Roger called me called hisarlik
back-to-nature Mangano quiche you other
sure papilla al pipila Tiger now poppy
laughing laughter - attack on Mexico now
korean-born doctrine Annabella villain
to them will meet me yes Ram I'm William
Jurgis when I'm anthem Milwaukee Almaty
Rasta namu document railroad mid-pacific
rollin mr. Jean King abetik Osman Todd
mirga author to me Orchestra might fail
State Kenya issues he goes Mago de la
fere taken again as contra mundum Oh
garlic naan testicle moon crashes of
Shawnee David William our dear that feel
actor yes because he goes
occur om again trend by mo Minden
keep on you there
and you
Munzer megawatts naked unlucky Daniel go
yes from
the monotheism an effective deposition
Bashara but your bad reputation in the
autumn state much because I do you
concern my just be another unipod occur
ayatollah forget river and after Nicola
well apotheca telephoned
again
image or signal at oh my god
just let me zoom out
anyone who suited my foot
from Lebanon the insult zr do area
writer-director a very sharp idea home
it's also said a little heart in
muhammad another cabin catalunya adults
arabs Anyang alone but inhaling a leaf
LaFollette ravi ravi i can imagine i
remark that for all of us so football
after Fatima near something
huge calendario cerebral edema shakily
mr. Giuliani my endicott ellenborough
thought of in share Owaisi
hey Tony Shaughnessy yo.hannes
so here's a morning Anna leave him too
many acid in Owenton DaCosta Talia
veritable cone who cannabis Abbott lucky
i'm @hardwick a certain Belconnen late
ever stand i manifest a limited by the d
he is dead - no sign of it why the lost
along hadith de la maquina BR Madrid
either of you an official business law
Aquila some [ __ ] hollow sack be
wrecked Eagleton to be shambolic after
Louetta zero while I had in chakra
dududu character mother or a no Solano
saya Tony is that this man is a battle
mode Authority well how about the Hadees
Albert lost o Mahadeva Sally she
that no one hand on the jamel looking
unfamilar before you but not a model
but react after certainly no row here
how or not at the sermon no salaam
Israel from Russia loveless Andre zippy
against a writer-director dependability
governor
yep it's a new lock step will get penis
supporters Elizabeth and I could do more
someday looking at the minneapolis over
to be honest about see me enemy heroes
Co concealer / Brown
I wonder because I just kept at you
yes to me as heads
excuse me
Oh a so stupid still supporters
inaudible to move the studio who lives
here ecstatic Irish master his minions
distil drug in a resilient epidermal
elaborate industry of suet she resisted
analysis tissue studied with prosthetics
that focus question available
didn't lead to much money that is okay
you should really just chill on ice
they are Muslim artists Bacardi a
serious videos not personal enough we
thing is opposed to just being proper
Scotty
you're the Syrian boo
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the surgeons are considerable
[Music]
from Sweden the square
Ruben muslin writer/director
[Applause]
I'm so sorry
you scared me another busy night it's
been left on the bar
they have nothing else right Wow you
check that belongs vacuum okay you know
it was that bad on to a test or someone
so good deal not okay you wanna you're
standing so her again i entreated so no
idea
hmm as a half of the week I wasn't here
that's me doing your veto so he'd have
reinforcements literacy you know I think
that we are moving after second degree
what cool
do you remember what happened between us
the other night we were here yeah no map
to that though Rivas yes mmm
we got in a cab went back to your place
no missing something you open a bottle
of wine we sat down we too
are you getting something specific you
know you've got something berries why
don't you just come out and say because
I want you to say it I want you to
remember it why is it so hard for you to
come why is it so I don't understand why
it's so hard for you to say this why did
you say it yourself why you didn't want
to say it
you were inside of me that's what
happened you remember that yes listen
that is part of it yes it's a big part
of it it's also part of man had a woman
you know
good pins up yeah that meant something
did it not absolutely okay what did it
mean to you I really enjoy myself okay
good just keep your voice down be it's
just that someone
yeah I like you and I have an emotional
connection to you and I'd like to
explore that because that's important to
me I don't just go have sex with just
anybody I you know I have to have that
do you just go have sex with just
anybody
excuse me do you just go have sex with
lots of other women is this something
that you do a lot private question whose
name uh so is being inside me pretty
pregnant so I'm asking how often you do
how often would you say that you take
women that you don't know very well and
have sex with them and be inside them do
you not remember yeah yeah you know
their names yeah yeah always always yeah
yeah so what's my name I know your name
okay then good what is it this is stupid
anyone that would know somebody's name
would just say of course I know your
name I know you know what is it
I'd forgotten how good all five of those
movies are the prankster the romantic
the fatalist the doomsayer and the
triumphalist these are art types glibly
these archetypes glibly suggest our five
directors and what they've been able to
pull off with their corresponding films
at first blush nothing really has
anything in common as you can tell from
these clips they are so completely
distinctive yes of course they're all
contemporary and yes they're all
intimate not big sprawling epics but
what I find that really binds them all
together that I can sort of find in
common is their characters it's the
character or characters and the triumph
of those characters in each movie I
don't mean that the characters are
somehow victorious in fact you could
argue that none of them is what I'm
suggesting that all of these movies
unless her hands could have been
allegories or even worse movies about
issues Tony and Yasser from the insult
could easily represent two sides of the
Middle East question but what they
really represent is Tony and Yasir two
flawed human beings who can't escape
from their past and their own natures
Marina and a fantastic woman could
easily represent a fringe character and
a preset preset non accepting society
but marina really represents the
character herself the triumph of that
aptly aptly titled movie is a marina as
a flesh-and-blood character who succeeds
beyond the movie around her in loveless
borås and the Zegna as self-involved and
disquieting as they are make us believe
in the soullessness of contemporary
Moscow nothing that is an abstract
but in a societal vacuum that has in
fact created the two of them Maria and
Endre in Bonn on body and soul could
easily stand for the damage victims of
their own uncompleted selves and yet
what we immediately see are two actual
people longing for each other they
represent nothing they just are hell
even the deer don't represent anything
they're just deer and Christian in the
square the well-meaning but clueless
curator somehow sells the absurdity of
his world only because he is a character
who is both unique and recognizable a
lesser character would have spun that
movie out of control all of these movies
work and work gloriously because of
these vibrant alive protagonists they
take us by the hand and guide us into
the world of those movies what the great
movies do is introduce us to singular
characters and make us immediately care
what happens to them we will accept any
world no matter how absurd it is if we
are led to be fully realized by fully
realizing triumphant characters on those
terms
all of these five movies succeed and
they succeed magnificently I was
remarking the other day I was looking at
the number of films that have been
nominated over the years and recently
we've had a number of movies that have
had first-time filmmakers two years ago
I think four of our five filmmakers were
first-timers that's not the case this
year at all and in fact a number of our
directors actually all of them have some
sort of Academy experience
ziad dough Ares first film West Beirut
was submitted by Lebanon in 1998 ildikó
and yetis my first film my 20th century
was submitted in 1989
Sebastian Leo's movie Gloria was Chile
submission
four years ago and Ruben uhlans
force-majeure was shortlisted three
years ago for those of you who get a
kick
watching grown men cry I urge you to
watch the YouTube reaction of Ruben not
getting nominated that year and of
course we have Andre as Ison says
Leviathan which was nominated that very
year you could argue that he robbed
Ruben of his spot and so I'll leave it
to the two of you to work it out later
so they're clearly the filmmakers you're
about to meet are not one-trick ponies
they have been succeeding their craft
for some time and we catch them in
mid-career enough of that I would like
to introduce our first director or the
director of a fantastic woman sub ASEAN
Lily Oh
[Applause]
Sebastiaan would you be good enough to
introduce any cast and crew that you
have here today yes
yeah hi
so the actor Francisco Reyes is here
Thank You Francisco the co-writer
Gonzalo masa producer or CEO hardware
producer Rocio Holloway the fantastic
DOP even community Cerreta producer
Marian a tired from Germany than in
aitikaf ski from completes and films and
my dear friend brother Juan de Dios Lara
in the main producer of the film
yeah they might missing someone no our
next director in Doug screaming ildikó
and Yeti from on body and soul ildikó
what about you do you have any of your
team here oh yes yes
although our main actress Alexandra
Bombay is stuck in some airports but I'm
I'm said that she is not here but many
members of my magnificent crew is here I
start with the producers on - mohei
which when we started the film and a
master has he and Monica made the main
producer of the film and I'm so happy
that Teresa lie or editor could make it
and he's here with with us please please
stand out and Emily Lang project
production designer a fantastic woman I
must say Adam Abhilash Adam or composer
even a [ __ ] of each costume designer
Sophia Moo he cast director casting
director and she's not a member of the
crew but a very important person for the
film Agnes how much ahead of the
hungarian film fund thank you for all of
you that's how you have a number of
people here is there anybody left in the
hungarian film industry and hunger it
and there are some coming so they'll be
here for tomorrow I hope and tonight we
have a little reception together just a
Hungarians okay
so all of you Hungarians are invited so
we'll get the we'll get the address
please welcome the director of the
insult Z odd dou Eric all right your
turn who do you have here with you I
have the director of photography Tommaso
thoroughly and the producer of genre our
dear actors who came from Beirut
Christine Shiu Li Camille Salome
we call him also professor Kelly Cellini
demo of our boot
Rita Hayek the costume designer Lara
camis and my longtime partner
screenwriting and lovely partner is her
well - Matt the screenwriter now is
Lebanon having a big party tonight and
we're invited that one too Lebanon is
always causing problems the director of
Lovelace
excuse me Andre Zijin selves and ray do
you have any of your your cast or crew
here producer cart in the alexander
radiance key
a compositor filmer Evgeny Galpin
composer that's all that's all so you're
not so much as having a party as maybe
cocktails or yeah he was here what three
years ago four years ago with Leviathan
so he's onto my ways three years ago
yeah 2015 yes the director of the square
room in Oakland
[Applause]
so there's there's a new YouTube video
now right yeah exactly am Swedish
director freaks out when he gets
oscar-nominated but I can start to
introduce the producer of the square and
force majeure hey Eric M adorbs that
I've been working with together for 15
years and he he also participates in the
first Swedish director freaks out when
he misses out on Oscar nomination so
it's also we are working together a lot
and then we have let's see now
yes territory that is doing a fantastic
performance in the film an American
actor the main actor Klaus bung that is
going any great performance at work and
Anna Khalil the applaud that we also saw
in the scene that is a actor Yousefi
knows by the production designer your
cup cool singer editor and then I also
will like to say that we have the head
of the Swedish Film Institute on asana
is here and they are paying for the
party we are going to have tonight III
of course I haven't been invited to any
of them but I'm gonna figure out which
in which order I'm going to attend all
of them question I'd like to start with
is Sebastian how how did this movie come
to be with what is the genesis of it for
for you because it sound like has been a
long time in the making yes we were the
starting point was a question what would
happen if the person you love dies in
your arms and and that's somehow the
worst place for that person to die
because for some reason you are the
unwanted
the rejected one so you would have to
call the family and let them know and
that seemed like like an interesting
starting point but then it didn't really
clicked until the idea of this situation
happening to a transgender woman
appeared and and that was an important
moment in the process and it was there a
key moment or was a slow realization or
did you see somebody and it just it just
clicked that's no it was just I was with
my dear co-writer and we were like
talking talking talking and suddenly the
idea popped up and was like we frist it
was like we couldn't continue writing
because because because it sounded very
moving very very touching but at the
same time I knew at least my head was
filled with cliches
so it was like okay we need to we cannot
continue writing we have to meet who is
out there and I wasn't sure if I wanted
to make the film I was it sounded too
dangerous you know full of traps and
which is which is a good sign but a
scary one and then I mean I mean to make
a long story short we we met the main
actress but we were looking for for
advice force for a friend someone that
could let us know what being a
transgender woman means in a country
like Chile or in a city like Santiago
and we met danila and and after that
meeting I realized I wanted to continue
the process of writing the script did
you meet her through through casting oh
no no just one click away like through a
friend yeah but then Danny was working
at a hair salon some I picked her up
from the hair salon we went to have a
coffee we sat down and I was like mmm
so fascinated by her and and and I loved
her immediately
she's very funny witty political and
very very smart and then and then I
realized started after that conversation
that I that I wanted to make the film
and and that I I was not going to make
it without a transgender actress and
then I was very happy because the Neela
accepted to become our cultural adviser
or friend of the project but then it
took me like a year to realize that the
cultural adviser was the star so it
happened from within and it was a very
organic and gradual process of like
pulling a thread until things unfold in
a very mysterious way did you did you
workshop it with with her did you or
just you just knew that she she could do
it or ahead you did you film some scene
did you do any test
no no I'm it was all or nothing you know
the thing is that the Neela is very
young she had some acting experience she
had made a couple of music videos some
theatre a small film she has been a an
opera singer student for a long time she
transitioned in a country like Chile 15
years ago so she was in a certain way
like a a pioneer when there wasn't even
vocabulary for doing something like that
and so I knew she was a force of nature
and a real artist
and then but then that doesn't mean that
when I sent her the script she didn't
think I was completely insane
and she was like you know I don't even
know how to drive and you want me to
drive you want me to fly you want me to
face wind storms and you want me to sing
to opera arias and are you insane you
know and I was like no I think you can I
think we can do it and I was like I hope
you know and then she said I need three
days and and she took three days I don't
know what she did and then she called
back and said okay I mean it'll take her
what about you I'd like to point out
that it is if you don't mind it's been
17 years between movies for you so this
one is a long long time coming but it
didn't it's not something you've been
thinking about for years and years it
just it's something finally it broke
through yes actually it's I think it's
the fifth or sixth project I I wrote and
this huge gap and although I wrote it 10
years ago
it it wasn't dragging for 10 years
generally I take a year at least to
write a script and rewrite it and before
applying for for support I really want
to have it ready and in this case I just
wrote this in less than four weeks it
was a very passionate very short period
it was very similar for to automatic
writing I must say I barely slept
and when much later I wrote
second draft it remained quite similar
to the original one which is also
uncharacteristic because I am I'm cruel
as a director with myself as a writer so
I throw out things and rewrite and so on
and somehow the whole thing started by
feeling by very powerful feeling it was
a very spring European spring where
there are seasons where you that the air
is chilly but you feel in the air the
promise of spring and all these hidden
feelings and energies start to to move
in you and your heart nearly bursts of
this energy and we share all this
feeling but we we don't speak about it
and that was just a starting point I
just considered so often ourselves as
huge rocks with a very thin layer of
moss which is culture and habits and
secretly all this what we don't speak
about is motivate us and guide us
through life and I wanted to make a film
about this energy to bring it to the
surface so it it was really a writing
process I had very quickly on the same
day when I just thought oh my god I want
to make a film about this this sort of
feeling this about this in a world which
is secretly guiding us but nobody speaks
about it I had two characters
the same days they I didn't have to
construct them somehow I had the feeling
I know both of them very well also the
man also the the woman they are both
very important for me equally important
and then I wanted to put them in a
situation where they are forced out of
their very comfortable but very
miserable little cage and I swear I
don't know how the idea of the shared
dream came to me but I thought this is a
good dramatical tool because in real
life if you encounter somebody who who
say oh my god I just read the same thing
as you
the next day you you just can't go to
work and say oh hello let's have a
coffee you have to do something you have
to explore that so it it was like a
motor and from that moment I just had to
watch them and write down what I see
that was it
Elda co has been teaching in the
Hungarian film school and a number of
her students were actually crew members
on the film the camera team quite exotic
Zi but about what about you where did
that I know you wrote this it's a very
interesting situation
he wrote this with a screenwriter he
just just introduced us to who while you
were writing this you were in the middle
of getting divorced the two of you I
mean that was not a it's not something
that you brag about but this is a but I
wrote it with sure well yes we were we
were splitting up we were divorcing but
it was a successful divorce I mean I
could tell you if if you want to March
that point yes if you want to know how
to divorce successfully come back I'll
give you advice so but what was the
genesis of your film was it an incident
was it a something you read in the
newspaper is just something I going to
tell actually a few years ago I was
living in Beirut and I used to collect a
lot of cactuses and I was that morning I
was worrying my plants and there was a
water that leaked from my balcony onto
the construction workers down there it's
just very similar to the beginning of
the film actually so the water came on
this construction where we started
exchanging insult you know he would say
you know son of a capped on getting
bigger and then I threw him a big insult
a very offensive one that there's no
what happened to be standing behind and
she says yet you cannot use that
specific word it's very very hurtful
very insulting why don't you go down and
apologize so I went down I was on the
third floor I went down and I met the
guy in his 50s I said like I want to
tell you I really apologize and he was I
guess he was very hurt he didn't respond
and that was the end of the story it got
resolved very quickly a couple of days
later I think I was going up the stairs
and walking down the street and I said
what if the story starts with a very
banal insignificant totally stupid
incident but does not get resolved
instead of getting resolved it gets more
more more complicated so the question
that I asked myself mark at that time
kid in Lebanon
you can use an insult and have it go
until it becomes you know strife can you
cause big riots on the streets if it's
like this and then during we start
asking a lot of questions and we find
out that in the Middle East yeah you
can't stop definitely you can and then I
said what if it gets all the way to the
presidency and I wanted to see is it
credible and during that time I don't
know if you and they ladies and
gentlemen when there was a fight in the
White House not in what house between
one of the professor and a policeman and
they got in a fight and Obama had called
him to the that the White House to
reconcile I don't remember the exact
name you remember that so I said you
know if in the White House you can have
a president interfere in a personal
conflict between two people then I could
probably do it once I lock that I had to
find out if I had a legal case so I
ended up hiring my mom who was a lawyer
and I said mom I need to consult you
about certain laws in Lebanese law if
you insult somebody's that considered a
libel is that considered crime and we
discovered that in Lebanese law in fact
there is a lot I think law number 228 if
i insult you or your nationality are
your religion I could go to jail and if
I could prove that you hate me you
physically aggressive me because of that
type of insult that I did to you you
could potentially get acquitted so I
knew at that point that I had a legal
case so I hired my mom and then after
three months my mom is very radical my
mom is a as a you know very activist so
you know we clashed and part of the
clashes that we had after I finished I
asked my ask so well and I said look I
have this idea why don't we start
collaborating it was our fourth phones
together so we started writing it and to
tell you the truth it was an extremely
pleasant experience writing it because
just to give you a little bit of
background I I come from a very
left-wing family in Lebanon my mom was
very militant she actually our point did
carry weapons in
ta she's she's if we call it and I don't
want you to think it's a it's a judgment
it's not it's just a statement it's just
an observation
my mom is left-wing and I grew up with
that mentality you know what 1975 the
civil war started and we were on that
side of the conflict all the left-wing
side of the conflict
Joell comes from from the opposite camp
sure well comes from she always texts me
before I say she says don't ever say I'm
far-right I am the far-right I said okay
what do you want me to call you
she says call it I'm sympathetic to the
right movement so I'm as a respect to
you I said so I come from a family that
has sympathy to the right-wing movement
I think it's a little bit more than that
but just so she grew up actually we grew
up in a civil war Lebanon was divided in
1975 you have the left versus the right
you have the left which was more leaning
toward the Palestinian the right were
leaning against the Palestinian is for a
very complicated takes way and then we
grew in the very hostile environment she
was literally considered a perfect enemy
to us and I'm not talking about
ideologically different only we were
going through a war I mean that was
200,000 people were killed it's very
serious at that time so when we decided
to write the story mark it happened very
organically we did not plan it we did
not decide it just happens that slowly
the the courtroom drama scene in which
the female is defending the Palestinian
she wrote them and all the scenes that
the right-wing lawyer I wrote them we
kind of swamp and what it was actually
it allows you to have a little bit
simple empathy for your characters am I
wrong sir well this is anyway this is
how we did yeah so it was it wasn't like
a dialogue you know we knew the subject
so well while we were writing so well
because we were coming from opposite
camps so in a way I could say it's
autobiographical maybe can we say it's
out of my reference I still think you're
far right but that's okay
[Laughter]
gee I wonder why they're not still
married you know what's interesting
about courtroom because I read somewhere
that you did all of this research about
courtrooms because so much of his film
takes place in the in a courtroom but
read saw resaw the verdict and judgment
in Nuremberg 12 Angry Men and LA law in
fact there's a quote of yours that said
Americans love that [ __ ] we've got the
courtroom down pat I highly recommend
the film my friends and the audience I
don't know if you have the chance to see
it really is a film that marked me
forever it's done in 1963 by Stanley
Kramer
it's called judgment at Nuremburg is
that you agree what a great movie I mean
God it's a three-hour movie three-hour
and you don't flinch your eyelids don't
close how compelling that film is really
and it's so nuanced I during the writing
I saw that film over and over to
understand how did they do it how could
you hold a three-hour film and not lose
it and then another film after that
which was also very influential which
had happened to see during the war also
while I was growing up in Beirut Sidney
Lumet's films called the verdict and a
great movie and there the character in
the verdict played by James Mason the
character in the film was called ed
Concannon if you remember I based I
wrote the profile and I wanted to guess
somebody who is so reminding and I chose
professor Kamil selling me to play the
cat kakarrot character was really great
movies American have perfected the art
of courthouse you guys are the best
Andre when we saw you last year with
Leviathan did you know you were going to
make Lovelace
No I'm shaking very unnatural history
insurance would - neighbor use closet
Sedna was most velikiy my field my
father's voice and a super scary genie
in Arabic mana our story you could say
also started with the divorce with the
Ingmar Ingmar Bergman's movie in English
it's sin from America term America
widens Tom Godot was a Conchie liquor
Tina Liliana he substantive oddities him
yet similar to Manasa will use it mister
adapt irritated scenario scenario
Bergman ie snake knee was no history of
race he throws musicals was me really me
tag Dahlia so in 2011 we finished Ileana
and this dream to adapt Ingmar Bergman
it's movie into a Russian reality
started seven years ago with the ending
of the shoe as a film or as a television
series do it's my catalyst do a traced
glove che steep is olive they wanted to
do six episodes so most early sketch was
most realistic Brava
yet I didn't stick would producer carton
Ileana Alexandra Nechita peer-led my
Stella sketch was most publicity pro 3
para hablar de Julia we dig a very least
remaster enemy extorting I'm ugly the
Great Synagogue so they start trying to
get the rights for the scenes of our
marriage and the producer fully
supported this idea of adapting scenes
from a marriage and there are four
rights holders for the movie and three
were on board but the fourth one would
not budge yes cook Elliot modalities do
you Boris tell Olivia fun moves as a
conscience linear for CSD listening of
camp really Sudha it should have
hasta la da da and I see IndyCar
Kombucha leaders will todavia topology
to know this took several years we tried
to get the ribs from the fourth rights
holder and you know we started Leviathan
we made Leviathan we finished Leviathan
we went to can and this right session
problem was still going on okay Fitness
time goddess agenda not cool issue of
priests here at home khakhra supposed to
not use any volunteers casually Papa
scrap of security able to touch it vomit
Eva we use treaty Chileans me what area
it history it was mighty was history
Stockman is basically a screw here a
diversity idea Liat impedance to a good
until in 2015 in the summer of 2015 we
found an article in the Russian press
about this volunteer movement in Russia
who looks for missing people and these
two motives scenes of a marriage and
this volunteer movement sparked and
created the idea for Leviathan talks to
know such as Kenya snow be some Nene at
the most two cars the city of Zahle two
visual cartoon and they're gonna pretty
much to my social knowledge I didn't
slow feeling manager supposed to it's a
chaotic even inspiration story and
Liana's non-ebola Pascal cool nila Bush
carotene assertion about Hamas throw in
there without a depth without a doubt
those who saw Bergman's film and see
that it served in the end just as
inspiration for loveless because it
ended up being a completely different
film right you know it's remarkable that
it without the volunteer movement
without the volunteers who go looking
for the for the lost boy or the missing
boy I'm not sure if there are any
characters whose humanity comes through
so they are with without a doubt the
most sympathetic people in the in the
film
maybe I'm sure he speaks perfect English
[Laughter]
Ruben Ruben this is uh I'm sure that
it's got to be a convoluted to answer in
your part how did the whole idea of the
square come to you and how long ago is
this is something that's been just any
for a while or is it all of a sudden you
it popped up no it actually started with
with me and Eric we were making a film
that was called play and play was
inspired of events that took place in
the city where I live in in Sweden in
get de bourree and it was a group of
young boys that was robbing other young
boys in the center of the city in the
mall for several occasions and we got to
know about this incident because Eric
showed me a newspaper article about this
and the thing about these robberies were
there was a lot of things that was
interesting with him but the boys were
really really small it was like 12
between 12 and 14 years old and when I
read through the court files you could
tell that they were doing these
robberies in a mall where where there
was a lot of adults around them and it
was very very seldom that any adult
interacted and tried to help the kids
so the bystander effect if you are
familiar with the bystander effect you
know that we get passive we don't know
who should take responsibility when we
are in public spaces was very strong but
it was also like that the kids world and
their dance world were taking place on
two parallel events that the kids didn't
ask for help and the adults didn't help
and I talked to to my father about this
and and he's brought up in in Stockholm
during the 50s and he told me that he
was when he was six years old his
parents put an address tag around his
neck
and wrote the address to to to where he
lived in which apartment he lived in
wisp Street and then him sent him out to
play all alone in the center of
Stockholm and when he said it's it's it
was obvious that it happened an attitude
change in society that back in the 50s
you looked at other adult as someone
that would help your children if they
ended up in trouble and today it's
almost like odd result or a potential
threat towards our children and this is
even though like Society have not become
more dangerous in Sweden so the the
criminality have decreased sir in a
decrease yeah and it's decreased now
going down yeah so so it's less
dangerous actually but but the paranoia
have increased yeah and in this context
me and a friend of mine Cali boom on
that is a producer is like 75 now and he
had been working with a lot of Swedish
directors like movie the Barry and Roy
Anders on them we came up with an idea
to try to break the bystander effect and
try to create a new social contract and
it was the square so with white mark
square we wanted to build an agreement
that is similar to the pedestrian
crossing you know a pedestrian crossing
with a couple of lines in the street we
managed to create a social contract that
the car driver should be careful with
the pedestrians but with the square with
these four lines in the street we should
create a social contract that we should
take care and be show trust and take
responsibility for each other so in a
way trying to create a new social
contract and I must talk a little bit
about the Swedish society because I
think the Swedish society it's
interesting if you look at trusts in the
Swedish society and there's a Swedish
sociologist professor that have made a
very interesting investigation about
different attitudes or for example you
Sweden and Germany and where we put our
trust and heap draw a triangle like this
and he put the state up here and he put
the family down here and he put the
individual down here so in every three
corners there's a state family
individual and then he put in where
Sweden US and Germany where we put our
trust and in Germany they put their
trust in between the state and the
family so it on this side of the
triangle and in Sweden we put our trust
in the state and the individual and in
the u.s. okay you have to say if it is
true now that you put your trust in the
family and in the individual and I think
that Sweden is a very extreme country in
many ways you know we don't put our
trust in the family we put it in the
individual but we have also have a great
trust to the States and suddenly
something have started to happen in
Sweden you know for an example they have
started to build a gated communities so
like in 2008 they started to build the
first gated community in Sweden and if
you look at the phenomenon of a gated
community I think in many ways it's a
very aggressive way of saying we don't
trust on what's outside of these gates
that's not our responsibility and we put
our trust what's inside the gate and
that's where our responsibilities so
some people don't think that this gated
community that this phenomena is popping
up is is scary but I think it's kind of
scary because we are suddenly leaving
out what's outside of the gates and
we're also showing that we don't have
the same amount of trust on on the
common project on the idea about this
state Sweden and I think that for me the
square was a way of trying to deal with
this topic deal on it on a society level
but also on an individual level and how
do I deal with with my trust how do I
deal with my responsibility and the main
character Klaus bang the reason that
that he's a
chief curator for a museum was because
this idea with the square was invited to
an museum in in a small city called van
a mall and we had an exhibition about
this idea and at the same time they
build the first square so it actually
exists now in Sweden three squares in
three different cities and venema was
the first city that that built one of
the square and they have used it in so
many beautiful ways for example it we
have had a lot of refugees coming to
Sweden and some of them they have said
you are not underage we have to send you
back and what they have done then is
that I have had manifestations in the
square so they went there and they had
demonstrations and the paper came and
took pictures of them and reported about
this so they have started to use it in a
quite beautiful way actually and in
Panama that that art exhibition and and
that they build one there that was
really the starting point of writing the
script and then I realized okay I want a
clothes barn that plays the main
character I want I want him to be a
chief curator and I want to challenge
him I want him to be put into a corner
because I wanted to challenge myself
because of course I say I'm a humanist
of course I say that I believe in being
equal and good through each other but
when when am I challenged in my in my
ideas about this so I I almost look at
the filmmaking as like putting up
sociological experiments and then
challenging clothes or a Christian in
every single moment and trying to look
at look at him and trying to make an
interesting example when we fail why do
we fail and
I'd like to ask the question about
casting now you explained anniela but
how did you go about casting the film
did you know who you're some of your
actors were going to be or did you
discover them through the the casting
process not really I mean it I was some
more concentrated in the writing and
then and then I think we put together
something similar to a national
selection of factors I mean in that film
there are one of the greatest Chilean
actors surrounding Daniella who is a
newcomer and and they were really
generous in protecting her and helping
her but yeah I mean until everything's
like you know you call someone on you
ask directly would you like to be in the
film you know we're all over the rest of
the cast were they all professional
actors yes yes yeah I would say based on
your film and certainly on Gloria and in
the films of Pablo Lorraine there's a
remarkable pool of acting talent in
Chile yes yes I believe so
we have great actors and Francisco
radius is the living proof of that
and why do you why do you think I think
that's true is it through it a theatre
tradition I think there is simply well
there is a big theatre tradition in
Chile and and I think it took you know
during the military coop and government
Chilean cinema was killed and then there
has been a process of reconstruction
that has taken 20-something years and
and I think it has been a process of
learning how to perform in front of a
camera for cinema
and I think in a certain way the
generation we belong to have been
growing alongside with the actors in
terms of understanding what performing
for a camera means but yeah we have
great actors until II yeah
can I say something
even if you don't ask me like oh you're
two leads one of them is a professional
actor actress and I gather your co-lead
I keep reading that he is one of if not
the major book publisher in in Hungary
and is not a professional actor yeah
he's 65 and never ever dreamed in this
widest and most horrible nightmares to
end up on a movie set and I am very
thankful for him to take the risk
because once I was asked by a fellow
filmmaker to to play a tiny role in in
his film I could choose my dress my
makeup I could write my own lines so I
was treated very generously let's say
and it felt like like really a tank
would go through me it was it teach me
to really have big big respect for
actors what they risk every day how much
they have to raise themselves otherwise
the performance is not so deep so I
really admire him for that yeah
I never made like you
a casting session with him I made just
one to prove him that he can make it but
already beforehand I told my producers
that he's the one we have the male lead
of the film at the same time for the
female role I knew that such an
introverted person as Maria can't be
played by an amateur because you can get
amazing amazing performances with
amateurs if you really understand their
deep nature and you don't ask anything
which is even slightly beside that and
[Music]
you have to respect these barriers
because immediately if they are out of
this sort of their own personality
they are totally clueless totally
vulnerable and it's just your
responsibility not to do that with them
so from REI I needed to find a very very
strong trained actress and Aleksandra
Barbie I know her form from theater
school I knew that she is very talented
she plays in a very very good theatre
perhaps the best theatre in Hungary this
is her first main role in film but she
is very different she is a very sexy
outspoken hot young girl I never saw her
without high heels like this and
impeccable makeup and so on and I wrote
for her especially thinking about her
the role of the psychologist in the film
and she came quite often to be a partner
to all these wonderful talented young
actresses
whom I try to work to to have casting
sessions and it came back to me again
and again to try Alexandra and she
didn't just play Maria she really
transformed into this woman and it was
an amazing experience to work on it
together it was more than a month months
and a half just spending time together
trying tiny tiny things how to walk for
example how such person walk and just to
just to find her Maria and on set I
barely had to tell anything to her
because she was the person and when we
had the two human actors I had to make
the male the deer casting as well and
it's even if you spend just a half David
deers you realize that they are so
strong personalities you can't confront
them if if if you see now the female
deer pits or you think yeah that that's
a female deer that's a doe but if you
see 30 lined up you immediately we say
yeah this is Alexandra this is this is
the one they are their body language
their character is so different you
actually cast the deer absolutely
[Applause]
by the way and it was not intentional
but the same thing repeated what was the
case with the with the humans Pizza is
prom she played in big buy the very big
American blow Buster's shooting in
Hungary and the goliad is an amateur and
it was very very hard to convince the
animal coordinator to accept to work
with Juliette because it mean that he
had to work with him for several months
on daily basis just to because you can't
train the year but he had to make him
accept my goal yet and then our little
team had to be accepted by him to be
close to be a partner so it was rather
working in partnership than training him
anything he keep that in mind the next
time you're casting deer in your movie
see out what about you you have a number
of actors in your from really strong
actors and not just your leads but but
some of the peripheral characters are
they all professional actors how did you
go about casting them I casted you know
I was living in Paris at that time that
I flew back to Beirut not knowing who
were the new generation of the actors so
I hired a friend of mine and I said let
me see who's today in the scene because
I haven't been to Beirut at a long time
and we started a very regular casting
you know they would come I would so
about 600 600 700 actors and I ended up
choosing the most of them the only
person that I didn't do face to face
casting with the guy who plays the
construction worker with the yellow
glasses yeah a camel Al Barsha
I wanted to have somebody who was as
close as possible to have a Palestinian
accent and I couldn't find him in
Lebanon
so I casted him on skype and I just the
reason I did not want to go to Jerusalem
are is its I have dual citizenship I
have the Lebanese citizenship and the US
citizenship a few years ago I went to do
the film the attack I went to Israel
with my US citizenship thank you
and and it's back basically it's illegal
I was prosecuted for it so I did not
want to repeat the same again of going
to journalist Jerusalem to do the actor
to do the casting so I said you know I
gotta face the reality either I look for
something somebody else or I try to do
it on skype and actually worked out on
skype
where I would send them the scene we
would read together and then this is how
I ended up and the nice thing about it
that I did he told me later that he had
never done a film because when we talked
and I said you know I want to know
what's your resume he was always very
vague about it
it's then he used to tell me go on
YouTube I have my film but what so I
found out later that I had never done a
movie before but what was so nice about
it that he got Best Actor at Venice Film
Festival so yeah
remarkable Andre there are a number of
actors in your movie all of them
extraordinary starting starting with
your your young boy are these actors
you've worked with before or do you hire
a casting director and he or she
introduces you to to all of these actors
and I know that you you you were an
actor yourself
yeah please do watch discriminable oppa
trouble to secure a new professional to
bleed this Nostradamus tomalak artino is
granny yes the poor hysterics issues
reported snip professionally mercury me
a table Mullen Carol Merrill McGill chic
when you upload vote Lana corrode Cahoon
CDC guarantee a crime I give a patent
Brigid McGill Oh miss Newman this image
this it away Inuit salsa of sensible is
this abdominal kazahstan
a manicotti Moglia deleted at plan I did
need instantly the Blanca asked mobility
via bank elongated Watchmen on the words
may not call the cry European Mowgli lab
it's a steak for ears cut off shores
depression and lemak Jeremy yeah yeah
new me remotes you better be a quick
writer so first I'd like to say that
I've previously worked with an
unprofessional and experienced actor and
after that experience I will no longer
work with one because the scene was very
simple it was
he was sitting by a tomb and he was
flicking a cigarette and they went
through two rolls of two rolls of film
so 20 minutes you know film and they
didn't get the effect he wanted so after
that he does not work with an
experienced actors anymore I mean any
[ __ ] sandy buchheit I can't do it I
just can't do it
when we issue a cure of actor of
professional the walnut dog at the Prado
certainly put what no canoes national
flu cheese nil above you Milotic
hesitation IG actor of Kotori
Cellini's viously sure ok auditory for
seconds watch a ver see what eruption
impervious lost alumni personage the
blister security attorney is Reina twist
Marianas Pewaukee illness corrosion
but it's a coronary at Krishna matter of
seconds which marionette appear we are
only of chemo no no she rose and not
oceany between his nine children
opportunity but she truly of national
cartina Ileana Olivia fun
what so I look for professional actors
and it's usually a long journey for me
it takes a long time and with love lists
I did have the goal of finding unknown
actors for the general public and so I
found I was very lucky to find brilliant
theatre actors Mariano's pubic is a
well-known theatre actress and it's her
first role in film and Alexei Roizen he
had minor roles in Andres film's Ileana
love happen and this is his first main
role in Lilliput about repeated
supportive kishke courageous person
Ashley and Natalie please Chuck Chuck
Tom which emulates a personage in her
Dino shoe is Iike OOP short a contactor
stoolie move Schmo which near about her
so it's a long journey with lots of
rehearsals and I'm looking for closeness
between the character and the actor it's
an intimate relationship between the two
of them so because I had so much golly
turtles Doga PD said actually he is
casting a nice little pocket or a bull
poster would you it's not olive Mongoose
cottage to vote with extraneous singing
lovely use technical downstate that
video is Lucy Trask a worid italy on
paradeen
a male accomplice would understand
assume we do th laconia edible you
occurred absolutely Ksenia impromptus
biome naturally idea Gorky gets kids
music in regards to the boy we also
looked through a lot of child actors it
was 250 kids and we found this uniquely
talented boy and for instance in his
main scene the one behind the door when
he hears his parents arguing the boy
actually didn't know what the to like
his parents were arguing about he was
crying about something very personal to
him and he doesn't know what but it was
like honest childhood tears and did you
as a director then tell him to imagine
something really terrible and react
accordingly yeah mr. stone in would come
with image tall
acha with myriad maybe she could little
which was nobility a Pathan Wadi Mick
it's that silver stud Ottoman bullet
what on stood attacker Brazil he got off
attack below for Simran
voice in DubLi miss Daly thank you so I
told him to imagine something he really
really dreams of something super
valuable for him and then imagine that
in one instance suddenly you'll never
ever have it and he thought about it and
he came up with something and he thought
of it for all eight takes and just about
this easy ago various related to a
tungsten when universally finale Teatro
Nacional de lipez Trudeau often I I wish
that we would have written in at the end
of the film and the credits that during
of the filming of this film no child was
hurt
I've read that you do multiple multiple
takes are you looking for something
specific or do you want to be surprised
easily as most to issue Cigna Sheen yet
the quest cards characters - such as
Buddha talks characters - suggests to
Jersey Shore Todd Lee bottom layer
Sakura needs to bleep double on Pross to
stay owed can't rally would see their
intestinal taquito pooja by
now so Chelsea Turks to miss Newman
treats it which is doubly true jets he
talks to Advaita Kartini astern of
mortgage Nita administering deulim which
is Nitschke Presley through this reason
oxygen but on the posterior Connery is
near leave this in clinic Usagi
mozzarella he possibly come on these top
scallops
so it is the other but I want you both
terrible in yet and he was monster so
it's a feeling that I get that's it's
about to get better and you know either
you tire the actor out and it becomes
more organic natural performance or it
doesn't doesn't at all for instance
sometimes I shoot 30 to 36 takes but the
scene in the Mork was only one take we
went through it technically with actors
and everyone and shot it once and yeah I
had called stop and that was it it was a
very emotional one take
Ruben you have a real ragtag cast a
little bit a little bit of everybody
what is your process and and were you
always planning on having the Elizabeth
moss role be being English or did you
just stumble upon her and say that's a
good idea
I I mean I I agree on all of you that
the costing process is something that is
like really really long and takes time
in order to find the right actor and I
really enjoyed the crossing poses
because I'm participating a lot in it
myself
by using the meetings with actors as a
possibility to do an improv on the scene
or on the setup of the scene so for an
example the scene where we saw with
Elizabeth moss in close bang I have
played close character towards Elizabeth
and I plead Elizabet when I was costing
clothes so I'm like been saying so how
do we solve this
the clothes and and he's sold votes
well what happened between us and what
what's useful for me when it comes to
that is of course that I get the
knowledge also about decision and and
the setup of decision and in what what
what are the challenges as an actor to
deal with this situation and this set up
but also I I think that I've I sometimes
get a fantastic line from the actor that
I immediately take and put into the
script so I'm using it also the costing
process in order to improve the script
and improve the dialogue of the script
and I mean when it comes to all the
actors in in the square or the actors
that I like I must say that it's very
often that you can see the struggle day
have in order to avoid losing face and
when you can see the struggle in their
faces when they're like trying to keep
up trying to avoid that embarrassment or
or the moment when they are like have to
admit that they have acted wrong or
and that is something that I I think it
all of the actors in the square have
that kind of quality
maybe not sure in order that plays the
monkey performance artist that I that is
like he's probably the only one that is
most losing face in the film I would say
and cherry yeah I let me also tell tell
you a little bit how I found cherry
cherry
I was looking at googling at YouTube
actor imitates monkey because I am very
interested in that and the reason that
I'm interested in that is that the
acting becomes so direct it's almost if
you look someone playing with a football
a soccer player
almost all of us know how hard it is to
yokel with the football and we can say
oh that's a great skill that player helm
when we see it and when it comes to
imitating monkeys it's just the same
thing you know even a kid can say that
one or that that girl or that that guy
that's the best actor when it comes to
imitating monkeys if it comes so direct
and I was googling this actor him
imitates monkey and I found a beautiful
clip of cherry when he is doing a demo
how he worked doing the motion capture
for Planet of the Apes and you have to
watch it google it when you get home he
has these arm extensions and then I
think the first monkey you're imitating
is chimpanzee and he walks exactly like
a chimpanzee every single movement is
like yeah it's it's amazing to see that
performance and then it says this is a
gorilla and it changes his body movement
and you can see it's it is a gorilla so
he is also actually one that only is
costed having a Skype call so I say I we
have a Skype : and I immediately offered
the role for four
sorry so so then is your script always
in flux are you are you open to
invention to accident during during the
during the actual shoot and then I I
also do a lot of takes but III I say
quite often I only buy myself time
that's why I do a lot of things I don't
know what I'm doing I'm terrified to let
people know about this but so I'm trying
to buy myself time and I'm ya know but
what I do I know what I thought was like
it kind of it was funny with Elizabeth
because I think she comes from shootings
where there may be have five takes or
something and then they have to move on
and I do yeah we work on one camera set
up the whole day sometimes so and what
we do in the beginning of the day we are
like trying out the scene we have the
script and we are following the script
but I think that every day when I get to
a shooting I think that I have to
rethink I've been written writing that
script as a product of a desk and then
when I get and start looking at it I
feel oh my god this is so wrong I have
been completely wrong and I have to
treat try to redefine the same route to
like find the obstacles and trying to
take them away and and what I do in the
beginning of the day we try out that and
the actors can take risks they can do
things that they wouldn't dare to do if
they only had five takes and they can do
things that sometimes feel silly but it
it turns out to be brilliant in the
scene and then we start repeating over
and over again and sculpt doing that
skeleton and I often it goes like it's
getting better and better and better oh
yeah this is going good you know and
then suddenly it goes down and it's
going no what's happening now you know
it's getting worse and you get so scared
that you will not be able to push it up
again and then you fight and you maybe
manage to push it up above the lever
that was before
and then we say okay an hour break now
and then when we get back on set we go
five takes left or everybody ready and
then we do a countdown and it's an for
me it's a combination of like you know
doing something that is very precise and
with that we have done a lot of time but
then make the present so important like
now it's an important football game we
have to win this game together and then
we go for takes left come on now and
everybody in the team have fine-tuned
the lighting the the sound the set
design everything and this five last
take it's very often it's the second
last take that that I used actually we
just just going to ask you if you ever
use the the ones that you didn't on the
set you didn't think we're working that
happened yes and it's very painful these
days you know I have also used the first
take one and push this in to do 50 takes
and then I were used to first take and
it's very painful that that day when you
go home you just feel like I'm not in
control you know even if I'm like having
all this time and I have a fantastic
collaboration ship with Eric to produce
and get that gets me all this time but
it's so painful when we don't reach the
top in the end of the day you reach it's
like and yeah Andre it it sounds like I
would feel from your move in movies
which are so precise that the script is
not tampered with it all when you're
shooting that the the words is written
there the words that are spoken by the
actors sometimes it's actually is was it
be sorry
this could be a sin in my field my thing
[Applause]
dude
I probably a good forgot of carrot in
this movie oh no pleasure cruise pasta
good at startup reactor church if she
wrote attack avoid he would not
producing it over a mini pocket ideal
disgusting precariously share Jacques
Chirac Rubens castle the premier - Stan
oh it text dialogue of precision about
securom awaited moment - musketeer with
dialogue - his dreams lava masonry text
stone area but the most opacity yes
league average or construct see some way
to an option is me and practice gives
rafinha
as to its appears new me Pasolini a
conjecture linear system area to
consciousness college Korea needed
keyboardist leukemia
first of adult cricket episode another
mystery the channel test utility choose
- - / evaluates each fragment evil cross
to delay good so we have a very long
development process we step onto the
shoot one year after starting the
project and like Ruben said we often
check how the dialogue works during
casting so we look at the text of the
script not its construction and you know
the final script is the final script and
it's often also the final edit edit we
very rarely lose some episodes in the
Edit because they're not working the
emotions not high enough but the final
script is always the final script or
encourage yeah technically you'd cook
the curves biryani of Guru this version
he cut out a better stupid theories
human aging the COG with Carter's niece
sati Gary but I must have option Phil
got off the bestest turkey or jet system
so it's all honest here so I look at
this development process as climbing a
mountain and then once you start
shooting you roll down this mountain
it's just a matter of like the film
needs to be fixated you already have it
as the odd what about you how fluid is
the script when you're when you're on
the floor what do you mean when I'm
shooting yes
I just like to point out something all
the films that I wrote I wrote them all
in American and English and then I
translated to the original Lang to the
native language oh so you're very
possibly in the wrong category possible
yeah too late now today no I mean I
write it an American because it's just
the language that I'm more familiar with
actually because you know some of you
know that I worked here such a long time
I work 18 years in Hollywood I started
as an electrician and I started that my
first film actually I was remembering it
I'm gonna see that lady today after I
finished with you here I'm gonna see a
friend of mine who gave me my very first
job when I graduated out of college and
it was Jamie Beardsley my first film is
a film called the munchies I don't know
if you've seen it it's the cheap version
of the gremlins
it's the Roger Corman movie actually
yeah so you know I work here a long time
I worked as an assistant camera grip an
electrician that was a time where I was
driving the film stock from the studio
to the lab from deluxe back to photo
camp so I guess having spent such a long
time here it just I develop a knack for
the language and when I say American
because I it's probably grammatically
wrong you say in English but to me it is
different American I still prefer to use
that terminology because it is such a
persuasive language American is so
practical it's not an analytical
language for me at least you know if you
compare their psyche between European
language and an American language I
think America is just so straight to the
point
and I can say that
as I juggle between three languages
between Arabic which is my native
language French which is my educational
language and American which is my life
being here so when I wrote all the films
that I wrote I wrote them in English
when I work with Joanne she write her
scene in French because she's fluent in
French and then I have to you know I
have a tendency to do a uniform script
in English because it's just the format
that I'm more familiar with and then
when I sit down with the actors we do we
don't improvise you know we discuss it
they say I think this phrase works
better the phrase works better and then
once we lock into it we go shoot it
there's no improvisation at all I mean
we can be flexible sometime but yeah you
understand the analogy about larrikin
yeah yeah do you agree yes
can I use the word yes I wrote an
American ildikó what about you is the
script can you work Kenny the actors
change it on the day or are you very
very strict on on what Ken can and
cannot be altered it depends on the film
on body and soul is a very sensitive
film to every little detail so the
dialogues were fixed we worked on them
together before the shooting the same
dramaturgical importance had lighting
and and set and even costume choices as
dialogues we we used them in a way as
dermatological tools and not just
decoration and no just creating a style
but every element had its dramaturgical
function and that's how we analyze it
with the cinematographer I'm also a
person who can think better with the
pencil and
and so we make storyboards but no
storyboard artists it's just for us very
ugly little drawings and every night
after shooting day I redraw them because
every shooting day brings something new
and on the way to to set we discussed it
with the cinematographer and it's not
just about it's it's really very much
about light as well generally we make
two three takes maximum eight when I
heard that you shot 80 days my god I was
so envious we had 38 and I like that
sort of rush of adrenaline that you have
to be exact and not just you but every
team member you have to be very much in
in command and totally focused on the
very heart of the scene
only then you can achieve because that's
what we have like a limit of time and we
really have to be very very present in
the moment and as I told somebody and so
it's such a sensitive film to detail I
knew even before making the film that if
we fail in tiny details we don't just
have something vicar but we just fell in
devoid we will have something ridiculous
or embarrassing or a really bad film and
I am so happy that so many Hungarians
are here because I needed these partners
I needed their sort of extreme focus on
the shooting they also in the
post-production even the grading was
somehow a drama to dramaturgical process
this one Sebastian what is your
relationship with the script when you're
shooting very open I tend to think that
script is always map but never territory
I belong to that line of thinking and I
am and I have this thing with characters
that I am very dependent and I need to
spend a lot of time writing them I love
writing characters but then I don't care
about them and they are like in a
certain way like a device in order to
that you can destroy in order to create
this kind of like a crack from which
something that belongs to the person
that is interpreting that role can merge
and that's what I'm really what I'm
really like obsessed with not not the
character but but but the people that
are giving an artistic battle in front
of your eyes so yeah I'm I'm known among
my friends for instead of saying cut I
tend to say keep rolling and I don't do
lots of cuts I do
eternal cuts
I mean takes so I'm like I say don't cut
why don't you you know do this or that
and then okay keep rolling now why don't
we tweak this and why don't you do it
more I don't know whatever strongly or
and then I keep rolling as much as I can
because I just can't stand and I'm sure
many of my friends here will feel the
same way because when you
you cut then everyone jumps in and
everyone's correcting you know the the
clothes and the hair and things that are
very necessary but but I just loved to
give the the energy alive and and and in
that sense I connect with what Ruben was
saying that there is something beautiful
about putting the actors in a in a
position where they are voluntarily
trapped in the game of having to defend
their characters and and I like the
tension I believe that from that tension
beautiful gems can can appear
the square and loveless the insult and
fantastic woman are all available and
independent films and near you and your
film and body and soul is Mike Mike oh
sorry and your help so so sorry and your
film is available immediately on Netflix
right you've just met the directors of
five of the best movies of the year
thank you very much
[Applause]
you